[Laughter]
[Music]
hey guys it's joe coy go check out my
movie easter sunday in theaters only
august 5th yeah
come on kfc give me some [ __ ]
questions
would you rather date a girl who laughs
at everything or laughs at nothing
lasted everything
someone that laughs at nothing is not
living
that's a zombie
and i can't stand being with people like
that and i don't care if you're a guy or
a girl or whatever you are [ __ ] laugh
what about like you're out you're out to
dinner with a bunch of people in like
the one douchebag
guy group in the group and hate
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that that that's breakup
yeah that's breakup because obviously
that's not funny
you're not
laughs well laughing
that situation
if you said that [ __ ] them both
[Laughter]
would you give up sex i don't even need
to read the rest of this no
would you give up sex to be able to dunk
a little [ __ ]
oh man what kind of dunk though is it
like a shitty scott sean bradley dunk
where you just like pink
or orchest like yuck yeah
yeah vince carter 2000 oh
god with the elbow
like the dominique
ah
no i wouldn't give up sex
ever i don't give a [ __ ] about dunking
would you rather have you know i can't
see i have my eyes are 51 years old now
so it's like i have to pull the [ __ ]
away and now it's just now it's really
far would you
would you rather have dust pants for
hands or
oh god
uh sweet smokers jelly sweat smokers
jelly sweats sweat markers now that had
nothing to do with my eyesight i just
couldn't read
yeah i do the dustpans yeah but the
message for your pants to go to the
bathroom your dustpan hands can't do it
okay jelly
do i answer these questions you answer
them
if you had to get one movie quote
tattooed on your body
what what would it be probably a fat guy
in little coat
yeah
fat guy little cup yeah yeah just like
this
about a quote from uh easter sunday out
on august 5th oh
easter sunday yeah it'll be joseph
my god joseph are you coming home for
easter
everyone's going to be here
would you okay this isn't even in the
goddamn game
this one you just wrote
this one's gonna be bad would you rather
be a mall easter bunny or a mall santa
yeah i would like i would like the
easter bunny there's no there's no
responsibility you know i mean
yeah i don't wanna i got the helmet on i
don't have to [ __ ] promise [ __ ] that
they're not gonna get
you know what i mean what do you want a
bike oh yeah it should be under the tree
like you [ __ ] wake up in his clothes
underwear and socks hey easter bunny is
just full of [ __ ]
could you beat tom cruise in a fight
absolutely not
that's my hero and i don't fight heroes
all right i'm goose he's always maverick
let's let's say for some reason you guys
were at odds he's gonna attack your
family yes and you're throwing down yeah
could you beat him then uh yeah
can you handle yourself oh yeah yeah
probably everyone in this [ __ ] room
for sure yeah yeah yeah cut two get down
never show up on time to a family event
again or never do stand up again never
show up to a family event i'm already
doing that
and i sell out arenas
twice per city
at least at least madison square garden
in november let's go
you know the coolest one i did was uh
chase center i sold out two chase
centers during
uh the playoffs so it was golden state
warriors on thursday and then me on
friday then golden state on saturday
meet on sunday and then they gave us box
seats to watch the playoffs and my son
and i are sitting in the box seats and
my son's looking at like holy [ __ ] dad
you did this
to give me fifty thousand dollars yeah
and i'm going so you're in that target
would you rather give the host 50 000
for a [ __ ]
what's better being a cowboy or a pirate
oh man that's a that's a good question
that is a really really good question
like when i was like six years old yeah
this is a great game
i love this question because i love both
of these characters i always wanted to
be a pirate you know what i mean you
[ __ ] steal [ __ ] you own a ship you
know what i mean
no one tells you where to go you just
[ __ ] go wherever you land you take
or a cowboy that's pretty badass get the
eat chew
god [ __ ] you
yeah you know what i mean what i owe you
how much [ __ ] you god
right
i would say cowboy yeah yeah cowboy i'd
be a cowboy all day yeah hands down
i love you nobody better you're the best
all right big thanks for watching ati
anybody else who you want to see any up
and coming comics anybody who you think
deserves to be a superstar comment below
we'll go get em make sure you subscribe
to the channel right now